hi hi hi good good how are you
[Music]
I'm in Jakarta I'm based in Noida in
India in Lagos Nigeria bridge
Massachusetts so some friends New York
City Mendocino County I'm in Northern
California one thing that makes open
that unique is that it's really driven
by artwork first and it was about
supporting and facilitating
experimentation and the general premise
is to pair artists and technologists to
work on a project for 48 hours and see
what happens in a time where it's not
possible to meet physically how we could
recreate the feeling of a lab in virtual
space everyone it's so exciting to be
here so the Media Lab is unique among
research labs in the world and that we
have always recognized the value of
bringing together different modes of
thinking and creative work it's also
incredibly important to find times for
spreads like this where we're trying to
express ourselves I'm really happy to
see like IDs coming up and see where it
can go and we're excited to see what
happens from the next few things what
we're trying to build is something that
can create music's depending on your
mood or emotional today if one was to
collect sound from an entire continent
could you actually zoom out from it and
hear it
the idea of an economy that is a kind of
horizontal economy pushes money across
the community yeah automated cameras
infer performance and film that can live
broadcast how can we give people a
better experience of the physical and
the virtual way for example outcome we
protest virtually right now we're
working on a project to explore grief
and loss in a digital space creating
empathy through connection to nature I'm
also interested in those stories where
people talk about why the Sun is the
most important object of them or why a
solar eclipse completely changed this
man's life pressing on
and about experiencing a place through
sound an online platform where we can
record our dreams together
whoever that's a football club do you go
to or I don't know a bowling club or
whatever you know nightclubs are no
different and we want to be able to
provide a space for people to like meet
like-minded individuals and still build
relationships I think we're trying to
solve like make it easy for people to
express how they are and understand how
they are online streaming service called
living sounds which we made for the time
of quarantine to connect people with
nature sound we miss this audience
performer interaction and that's how we
got to applause and maybe through
applause we can feel some kind of
feedback I'm so excited to see like what
happens in 48 hours but you know I the
next thing for me is like what happens
in two weeks what happens in two months
in two years
[Music]
it's rare and really special to be able
to be paired with technologists it's
something that I've never had that
opportunity before I think long has ever
had that opportunity where the world
seems especially starved for beauty
right now and it seems like our only
answer in the coming months is gonna be
something there's no I think the bigger
picture here with the collaboration is
to ask these important questions of how
does Cove in 19 and how does this
quarantine affect so many different
issues thank you very much take
[Music]